سداف في مخيم البريش في هذه اللحظات
انتشار اعداد من المصابين تكام من هذا
المنزل الذي دمرته مقاتلات الاحتلال
الحربيه داخل مخيم البريج وسط قطاع غزه
الاستهداف طال منزلا لاحد المواطنين حتى
اللحظه يتم انتشال اعداد من المصابين من
تحت ركام هذا المنزل مع ساعات الفجر
الاولى لا يزال هناك عدد من العالقين تحت
ركام هذا
المنزل منزل عائله شاهين في مخيم البريج
والذي دمرته المقاتلات الحربيه قبل
قليل هي سياره جا عندك الاثنين ورا
السياره ورا
السياره
حزه
خص خلص
تمام حمزه في
المدرسه منزل شاين في مخيم
البريج لا يزال عدد من العالقين تحت ركام
هذا
المنزل محاولات الان
لانتشال
عالقين تحت ركم هذا المنزل الذي دمرته
مقاتلات الاحتلال الحربيه في مخيم البريج
وسط قطاع
غزه بعد قصف مقاتلات الاحتلال الحربيه
لمنزل يعود عائله
شاهين
شهيد حتى اللحظه اضافه الى زوجته الشهيده
الاخرى يتم الان انتشالهم من منزل
عائ الان انتشال شهيده ثانيه من منزل
عائله شهين في مخيم مخيم
البريش
من داخل المنازل المجاوره لمنزل عائله
شاهين في مخيم البريج الان يعني طواقم
الانقاذ تحاول في هذه اللحظات البحث عن
اشلاء للشهداء في هذا
المكان